y aquí tenemos la curva de valoración
para la titulación de 50 mililitros de
una solución 0.2 cientos más de ácido
acético a la que le agregamos un poco de
hidróxido de sodio 0.0 500 molar y
nuevamente tenemos el ph en el eje g y
en el eje x tenemos los mililitros de
base que agregamos en el inciso a nos
dice cuál es el ph antes de agregar la
base es decir a los 0.0 mililitros de
hidróxido de sodio bueno vamos a pensar
en un problema de equilibrio para el
ácido débil nuestro ácido débil es el
ácido acético que se encuentra en
solución entonces si el ácido acético
dona un protón al h2o el h2o se
convierte en h 3 o más y como le
quitamos un protón al ácido acético
nos queda h3c o menos el año en acetato
ahora la concentración inicial de ácido
acético es cero punto 200 molar tenemos
una concentración inicial 0 punto
200.000 ar y supongamos que aún no
tenemos ningún producto esto fue lo que
hicimos en el vídeo sobre equilibrio de
un ácido débil ahora en el cambio como
el ácido acético se transforma en
aniones acetato la concentración que
perdemos de ácido la ganamos de acetato
y por lo tanto también ganamos esa
concentración de iones sidronio así que
al equilibrio la concentración de ácido
acético es cero punto 200 menos x
este lado nos queda x
entonces cuando escribimos nuestra
expresión de equilibrio acá
es igual a la concentración de los
productos entre la de los reactivos lo
haré un poco rápido porque esto ya lo
vimos anteriormente entonces aquí nos
queda x por x que corresponden a estas x
de nuestros productos entre nuestros
reactivos que en este caso sólo tenemos
0 punto 200 menos x porque no se toma en
cuenta el agua 0.2 cientos menos x
supongamos que x es una concentración
muy muy pequeña a comparación de 0.2
cientos así que podemos decir que 0.2
cientos menos x es casi igual a 0.2
cientos entonces si reescribimos esta
parte de la ecuación nos queda x
cuadrada entre 0.2 cientos es igual acá
y el valor de acá para el ácido acético
es 1.8 por 10 a la menos cinco entonces
usemos la calculadora tenemos 1.8 por 10
a la menos 5
0 punto 200 este es igual a 3.6 por 10 a
la menos 6 y si le sacamos la raíz
cuadrada x es igual a 0.00 19 x es igual
a 0.00 19
recordemos que x representa la
concentración de iones y tronío al
equilibrio entonces si esta es la
concentración de iones sidronio ya
podemos encontrar el valor del ph porque
th es igual a menos el logaritmo de la
concentración de iones sidronio así que
simplemente sustituimos 0.00 19 y
calculamos el ph usemos la calculadora
menos logaritmo de 0.00 19 es igual a 2
puntos 72
h es igual a 2.72 así que antes de
agregar la base es decir 0.0 mililitros
de hidróxido de sodio el ph debe ser
igual a 2.72 si observamos nuestra curva
de valoración también llamada curva de
titulación a los 0 puntos 0 mililitros
de base nuestro primer punto está justo
aquí este es el inciso a y corresponde a
un ph de 2.72 muy bien ahora agreguemos
un poco de hidróxido de sodio en el
inciso b nuestro objetivo es encontrar
el ph después de agregar 100 mililitros
de nuestra solución
0.0 500 molar de hidróxido de sodio
entonces primero calculemos cuántos
moles de la base agregamos como la
concentración de hidróxido de sodio
0.0 500 molar esta es la misma
concentración de los iones hidróxido la
concentración de iones hidróxido es
igual a 0.0 500 molar y recordemos que
la polaridad es igual a los moles sobre
los litros así que esto es igual a los
moles entre cuántos litros son 100
mililitros bueno si movemos nuestro
punto decimal una dos tres veces nos
quedan 0.1 litros así que para calcular
los moles simplemente multiplicamos 0.05
por 0.1 y eso es igual a 0.005 hemos
agregado 0.005 moles de hidróxido de
sodio
cuántos moles de ácido teníamos
presentes al inicio bueno regresemos a
nuestra curva de valoración
empezamos con 50 mililitros de una
solución 0.2 cientos mil ar de ácido
acético entonces calculemos con cuántos
moles de ácido acético empezamos la
concentración de ácido acético al inicio
era cero punto 200 molar y esto es igual
a moles sobre litros que como empezamos
con 50 mililitros teníamos 0.0500 litros
y ahora simplemente multiplicamos 0.2
por 0.05 eso es igual a 0.0100 moles de
ácido acético que teníamos al inicio
entonces tenemos un ácido que es ácido
acético y una base que son iones hydro
así que los iones hidróxido neutralizan
al ácido presente tenemos una reacción
de neutralización vamos a escribir le
tenemos al ácido acético que reacciona
con algunos iones hidróxido entonces el
hidróxido tomará el protón más ácido del
ácido acético este protón yo h - más h
más forman
h2o y como el hidróxido le quitó un
protón al ácido acético nos queda la
base conjugada del ácido acético el a
nyon acetato de h3c o menos muy bien
empezamos con 0.0100 moles de ácido
acético vamos a escribir 0.0100 moles y
de hidróxido agregamos 0.00 500 10.00
500 moles de iones hidróxido entonces
como los iones hidróxido neutralizan al
ácido acético todo el hidróxido
reacciona y esa misma cantidad que
perdemos es la misma cantidad de ácido
acético que neutralizamos perdemos la
misma cantidad de ácido acético entonces
0.01 menos 0.005 aún nos quedan 0.0050
moles de ácidos y neutralizar y al
perder esa cantidad de ácido acético
ganamos la misma cantidad pero de
aniones
entonces empezamos con cero moles pero
ganamos 0.005 y después de la
neutralización terminamos con 0.005
moles de añón es acetato muy bien ahora
calculemos la concentración de ácido
acético y de los años acetato ya
conocemos los moles pero necesitamos
conocer el volumen regresemos al
problema agregamos 100 mililitros de
base y empezamos con 50 mililitros de la
solución ácida entonces 50 más 100 es
igual a 150 mililitros y esto es igual a
0.15 litros
entonces calculemos las concentraciones
la concentración del ácido acético
después de la neutralización es igual a
tenemos 0.00 50 moles
0.00 50 y el volumen es 0 punto 1500
litros 0.15 0 0 usemos la calculadora
tenemos 0.005 / 0.150 esto es igual a
cero punto 0 33 entonces la
concentración es 0.0 33 molar muy bien
ahora calculemos la concentración de
acetato observen que para calcular la
concentración de añón es acetato son los
mismos números tenemos 0.005 aquí y el
volumen total también es cero punto 1500
así que es el mismo cálculo 0.00 50
entre 0.15 00 esto es igual a cero punto
cero 33
entonces tenemos la misma concentración
del ácido débil y de la base conjugada
así que conforme dejamos caer algunas
gotas de iones hidróxido en la solución
ácida inicial formamos una solución
conocida como solución amortiguador en
donde tenemos concentraciones iguales
ahora nuestro objetivo es encontrar el
ph y como tenemos una solución
amortiguador a podemos usar la ecuación
de henderson hasselbeck que dice ph es
igual al pk a más el logaritmo de la
concentración de a menos entre la
concentración de h
anteriormente dijimos que el caa del
ácido acético es 1.8 por 10 a la menos 5
así que el pk
es igual a menos el logaritmo de eso
usemos la calculadora menos logaritmo de
1.8 por 10 a la menos
5 es igual a 4 puntos 74 el pk
es igual a 4 puntos 74 entonces el ph es
igual a 4 puntos 74
+ el logaritmo de la concentración de a
menos que corresponde al acetato 0.0 33
/ h que corresponde al ácido acético y
también es igual a 0 puntos 0.33
entonces nos queda el logaritmo de 0.0
33 entre 0.0 33 esto es igual a 1 y el
logaritmo de 1 que a lo mejor ya saben
pero lo haré en la calculadora el
logaritmo de 1 es igual a 0 entonces el
ph es igual a 4.74 + 0 todo esto es
igual a cero así que el ph es igual a
4.74 es la mitad del punto de
equivalencia porque neutralizamos la
mitad del ácido y la otra mitad sigue
presente así que al usar la ecuación de
henderson
para obtener el ph encontramos que en
este punto el ph es igual al pk y
regresemos a nuestra curva después de
agregar 100 mililitros de la base a los
100 mililitros este es nuestro segundo
punto corresponde al inciso b y en este
punto el ph es aproximadamente 4 puntos